ça va très bien
alors ce soir c'est un blind test
spécial gens de petite taille en hommage
à notre premier invité jamel et à ma
femme qui prépare le blind test on va
passer aux jeux idiots
[Musique]
alors ce soir le jeu idiot est consacrée
à guillaume tell ce qui explique
l'accoutrement de philippe corti et de
ses deux amis
philippe et elouan place donc vous allez
tirer des pommes les deux sur la tête de
talia et de titia accessoires s'il vous
plaît donc je touche 2-2 attention chili
bon
pas sûr
ouais
maintenant hâte
non
[Musique]
fiable elles sont peu voire un replay
parce que c'est un acte absolument
extraordinaire que vient de faire
philippe corti on a un petit replay s'il
vous plaît serge sur titia bravo
m
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu